dopamine is a neurotransmitter which is  responsible for motivation euphoria  reward and this is a feel good factor  dopamine is a derivative of the amino  acid tyrosine from which it gets  converted to l-dopa and further get  converted to dopamine dopamine receptors  are present in the postsynapse and they  are g-protein-coupled receptors after a  while dopamine gets degraded into homo  vanillic acid by the enzyme monoamine  oxidase or catechol  o-methyltransferase  so in  depression both these enzymes are  inhibited allowing dopamine to sustain  in the synaptic cliff dopaminergic  pathways are plenty in the brain there  are mesocortical pathway nigrostratal or  the mesolimbic pathway among them the  mesolimbic pathway is responsible for  pleasure and  or reward seeking behavior  dopaminergic neuronal loss is prominent  in parkinson disease where the neurons  in substantia [ __ ] dies  watch the full video to know more